[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
whatsa Prof welcome back Walter welcome
back Martin it was a very nice
series that aired while we took a
break yes and uh I think uh people are
asking where's what's our Prof they
should know by now that at the end of
the year yeah yeah there's a a little
program and for a few weeks and then we
carry on with what's upov and it's not
like we didn't work they could see there
was quite a lot lot of work that went
into that yes yes yes we kept we were
kept very busy but yeah the Lord has
blessed all of that
and now we are at the beginning of a new
year 2024
and you know Martin so many things are
happening and people want to know where
we are in the Stream of time and some
people say you know is it really
necessary to know all these things Etc
so let's talk a little bit about the
current events and see where we are
heading as a people yes because the a
lot is buzzing about a lot of things
happening in the world and it's a lot of
fear mongering yes there's a lot of fear
mongering again so let's open with a
word of prayer then we can start the
discussion our heavenly father we thank
you that we are back here and that we
can start a new year with a lot of
things happening and we ask that you
will help us through this year and also
through the discussions Enlighten our
minds with the Holy Spirit guard our
thoughts and thank you for all of this
in Jesus name amen
amen now we're going to talk about Civil
War World War I are we prepared but as
you say there are so many other things
happening a new uh virus is in the air
called x 20 times more potent than than
the previous one and you know a lot of
fear-mongering and a lot of legislation
that they want to get into place as a
consequence of nothing yeah oh well
that's what we know knew at the from the
beginning and that's not going to stop
no so let's dive right into it this is a
quote from the review in
Herald in the last scenes of this
Earth's history war will
rage H so that's an
axiom there will be pestilence plague
and famine the Waters of the deep will
overflow their boundaries property and
life will be destroyed by fire and flood
we should be preparing for the mansions
that Christ has gone to prepare for them
that love him there is a rest from
Earth's
conflict so basically Martin we can
expect turmoil in this world MH we can
expect the time of trouble such as never
was we can expect fires we can expect
floods we can expect catastrophes by
land and
sea and we can expect
War but and let's not forget this there
are angels holding the wings yes they
are still holding on to it and how long
will they hold the winds until the
Servants of God are sealed in their
fors now the sealing time takes place
when legislation is put abroad that
makes of none effect the Commandments of
God that's it yes so this is coming mhm
it is going to
happen but we have a short window of
opportunity until the ceiling is over
yes so we are heading towards all of
this and pretty
fast here's an article from The
Economist and this comes from January
the 21st so it's very recent America and
Iran step closer to the brink of
war in the 100 odd days since Hamas
attacked Israel on October the 7th
President Joe Biden has sought to help
Israel win its war in Gaza and prevent
the conflict from turning into a
regional war with Iran and its
proxies it's amazing how they always
talk about the proxies but the West is
just as guilty of having proxy as
everybody else right isn't NATO full of
proxies multiple ballistic missiles and
Rockets fired at the AL Assad base in
Western Iraq according to American
Central Command Reports say Patriot air
defense batteries intercepted most of
them but some H the base concussing or
otherwise wounding an unknown numbers of
Americans and Iraqis either to America
has retaliated against local proxies MR
Biden will now face growing pressure to
take stronger action against Iran itself
it is a dilemma do nothing and America
looks weak retaliate and the president
risks a new war in an election year so
Martin are there rumors of War Y and are
there Wars yes so both of there so the
citation that we read is correct and the
Bible is also also correct according to
Matthew 24 if you have a war like this
it will be
cataclysmic because sooner or later they
will push buttons because they're
already threatening to push buttons yeah
and it's not just America and uh the
Middle East it's Russia it's China it's
Japan it's the Philippines they're all
involved Korea and South and North Korea
so there are plenty of rumors of
wars so the sun reports axis of Evil
kimyong un and Putin vowed to form a new
world order in chilling warning to the
West as tyrants ramp up united front
against the
US now here again just as you had in the
first and second world war you have
definitions of Who belongs to who yeah
who is the axis of Evil
and who is the Force for good right so
are people going to choose sides yes yes
they already do and that's actually a
very important thing because is there a
good side to
war no and if you were to take up arms
and shoot across the Enemy Lines to the
enemy over there how do you know that
you're not killing Brothers and Sisters
in Christ exactly that's that's the main
thing so if you are a Believer and
you're this side of the the fence
shooting that side of the fence somebody
like you just said and he's also a
Believer it's your brother now it's
interesting Martin that if you go back
to the time of the Civil War in the
United
States that really cemented the idea
that if you are a True Believer in
Christ you really should be a
non-combatant that's very true because
they it was was brother against brother
literally yes and and should we involve
ourselves our opinion has always been we
are observers right we are observers in
in what way are we
involved I think the only way that we
are involved and
engaged is by making firm
decisions for Christ and peace and to
make sure that you do not become
involved in any Access of
Evil now you see there's people that
believe that taking up arms is for a
good cause because it's a religious it's
good for Jesus couldn't that be a double
deception I'm sure it is if you take for
instance the Ukraine and Russia War
there are people that say they have to
throw bombs and get take up arms to
establish peace so you have to make war
to have to make peace to have peace in
other words one must overrun the
other Admiral Rob Bower chief of NATO's
military committee has called on the
west to prepare for an era of War adding
that the alliance needs a war fighting
transformation so they're preparing for
war right they're talking all over the
whole Europe and I mean in Sweden
recently they were getting ready and
everything is ramped up well let's read
it Sweden's defense Ministry warning to
brace for war s public into Panic the
Commander in Chief of the Swedish Armed
Forces General mik Biden who visited the
Eastern front of Ukraine in December
also spoke to the conference on Sunday
warning all swedes to prepare mentally
for the possibility of War as their
nation is just two steps short of NATO
membership the world is facing a
security Outlook with greater risks than
at any time since the end of the second
world war we stand with Ukraine with our
allies and with the rules-based
international order Martin do you notice
an insinuation there yeah that some are
rules based and some are not yes
exactly and we do so in word and deed as
an arsenal of democracy the civil
defense minister said all of this will
demand more of us than before and this
begins with the realization that
defending Sweden is a matter for all of
us and we understand from our friends in
Sweden that there is a lot of pressure
to join the movement and to prepare
yourself to fight for these principles
yeah you see the thing is I didn't put
it in this but in the article it also
says there were
people um stress buying you know
emptying the shelves and all of those
things on the threat of War so the world
is on the brink of
turmoil the angels are holding the winds
why are they holding the winds Martin so
that the gospel can still be taken to
the world yes and there must come a
climax and once the world has made a
choice either for God's way or against
God's way then the winds will be loosed
but that is not long off no you must
make that choice now that decision is in
front of the
door and this is the whole reason why we
are doing things like this
is's an article from
Breitbart this is all very recent
information leaked German military docks
warn of World War II with Russia by
2025 hundreds of thousands of troops
deployed in Europe so this is not just a
rumor anymore no this is actually
happening and the same happened in the
first the second world war things were
stirring the whole time
right up until it really happened yes so
the defense Ministry lays out details
for a possible path to conflict between
Russia and NATO beginning as soon as
next
month so in other words they expect an
escalation and escalation and then
eventually allout
War under the scenario laid out by the
German military the Kremlin would begin
a mobilization of 200,000 soldiers in Fe
and launch renewed efforts to capture
the Ukrainian Capital Kev which had
failed to do so at the outset of the
invasion in
2022 this would be followed by a series
of cyber attacks and other forms of
hybrid Warfare waged by Moscow intended
to destabilize the Baltic states now
they've been talking about cyber attacks
for a long time haven't they yeah CL
Schwab said that that will the co
pandemic will be like a mere disturbance
compared to what will happen now there's
been talk Martin that if a Cyber attack
hits the United States and it destroys
or puts out of action the grid what is
the estimate of how many people can die
9 95% I think they said 95% that would
mean that the entire population is
virtually gone right now whether it is
is like that or not this is the
information that is circulating in the
internet right now if you
take
2025 that they say there might be this
and we remember deagle said that there
will be this this decrease in
populations and there will be an
increase in demonic activity so what
let's let's just get this this into some
form of sequence yeah yeah so the winds
are being held back until God's people
are sealed when God's people are sealed
they bring the loud cry mhm the loud cry
is a window of opportunity for the world
to
accept the information of the Three
Angels and the fourth
Angel if they reject it then they become
part of the problem and they receive the
plagues once the plagues start falling
chaos breaks out everywhere then the
winds are yes loose even prior to the
plagues there will be tremendous
calamities and these calamities will be
blamed on those who do not want to go
with the system yep so we can expect
outbreaks of catastrophes and wars and
calamities to begin prior to the plagues
in other words while probation still
Ling for the world yeah while those that
have been sealed bring the loud cry and
then when the winds are
loosed then we have this scenario yeah
and we will see because the Bible talks
about thousands will fall by your side
10,000 at your right hand but it will
not come near you now we've been looking
at those verses for more than a century
and a
half and people say wolf wolf Martin
this is not wolf anymore
no I think we are on the brink of very
interesting things and there the other
thing that I also wanted to say on that
is remember that legal document said
that it won't be because of Wars so
could be because of natural disasters it
could be because of calamities and not
pandemics and and they also said
pmic so it can be say for instance that
grit failure happens yes which we will
see can also be caused by an Cyber
attack in a certain way but we'll look
at it just now all right well let's see
what Donald Trump has to say on the
issue hey Mr President thanks for being
here tonight thank you clearly it's no
secret that our country is in chaos the
world is in chaos what happened with
Yemen and the missell strikes the last
few days ukra ukine Palestine we don't
even know where the secretary of defense
is right now are we on the brink of
World War II I think with the closest
that we've ever been and you know Joe
this won't be a regular War this is not
going to be as I say army tanks running
back and forth shooting each other these
are weapons of mass destruction the
likes of which nobody's ever seen I've
seen I've seen them and uh this is
obliteration this is not a World War
like we are used to World War I World
war two were terrible horrible uh this
is uh so much bigger than that this is
you
know like
Annihilation and we have people that
can't put two sentences together our
president can't speak he can't speak a
full
sentence all right Martin there is uh a
certain percentage of electioneering in
there yeah yeah so we have to take that
with uh with the message but
nevertheless they are talking about full
scale wall yeah and he's like and he's
just it's not that he just says it now
he's said it quite a few times we made
an episode I can't even remember a long
time ago few years that also had the
same scenario but it's really escalated
since then it has definitely
escalated and then of course you have
the Doomsday Clock this comes from the
22nd of January 2020 4 the Doomsday
Clock update incoming as we're closer to
midnight than ever
before for those who aren't familiar
with it the Doomsday Clock is designed
to show just how close humanity is to
Global catastrophe caused by man-made
Technologies and this year it's set to
be updated on 23rd of January so M
that's very fascinating because we're
right there right there and isn't it you
it's going to be updated now uh this
doesn't even include even AI or any one
of those issues but isn't it interesting
that they also use closer to midnight
and the Bible also speaks of midnight so
does the world realize that we're on the
brink I think so all right here's a sad
question do God's people realize we're
on the brink no we fast asleep we
sleeping for at night I don't know what
sleeping pills they're taking but
they're
snoring is this is the prime opportunity
in the world's history to bring this
message to the
people now there's a lot of talk about
the elit preparing for this kind of
scenario isn't there yeah well you've
got all sorts of meetings also the world
economic Forum that we'll also get to
but it's all over the place the elite
are always they seem to know a lot but
the rest don't now you know it's not
only the elites but we will look at how
they're preparing by building bunkers
and this that and the other and if we
look on on a national level many bunkers
have been built by Many Many Nations
M and if you take uh that Serpentine
building in the Vatican that's even a
nuclear bunker so people are preparing
for these kinds of things and of course
presidents of the world have you know
been in the news for preparing bunkers
Etc but let's look at this
video Well mine's a little dark I just
feel a lot of concern that 2024 may be
the year of a Black Swan event this is a
national security event with high impact
that's very hard to predict powerful
people in the world you they see
themselves as utterly incapable capable
of actually creating a future in which
everything's going to be okay a colossal
Compound on the island of Kawai complete
with a massive doomsday bunker what is
it with billionaires in their Doomsday
Bunkers but I mean the question is what
do they know that we don't know they're
prepping for some kind of large scale
disaster I'm a bit worried about it to
be honest Mark Zuckerberg the CEO of
meta has started to prepare for the
Dooms Day there's something that Mark
Zuckerberg seems to know the how many
Have Seen the Last of Us in the zombie
apocalypse this 6' tall rock wall along
Kola Road in Pila has been jokingly
compared to the wall Donald Trump wants
between the US and Mexico the wall
protects billionaire Mark Zuckerberg's
700 acre estate you have that much money
when you're a billionaire you either go
up you either go up to space you go find
somewhere else to live or you go down
mea billionaire Frank Vander SLO
recently dropped $51 million on 2,000
acres of ranchland the Hawaiian island
of lenai is now almost completely owned
by Oracle billionaire Larry Ellis
Florida Jeff Bezos spent $147 million
buying two mansions on Indian Creek
Island while open AI CEO Sam Alman and
venture capitalist Peter teal have their
own little Arrangement where the pair
will take a jet to one of Teal's New
Zealand properties in the case of an
apocalyptic event teal has been fighting
local government for the past two years
trying to build his own 10 bedroom
compound directly into the landscape a
doomsday bunker with the bonus of having
one of the best views in the world as
the rest of the globe Burns Larry P he
now owns at least four that we know of
three in the Caribbean and one in fijas
that are virtually inaccessible to the
general public the billionaires they
understand that they're playing a
dangerous game that they are running out
of room to externalize the damage of the
way their companies operate eventually
there's going to be you know the social
unrest that leads to your undoing which
is why these same people are looking at
creating bom well they are preparing a
lot of bunkers on a lot of islands yeah
now Martin that is so
ridiculous because the Bible says every
island will disappear what are they
going to do then no but that's in the
great time of trouble when the plagues
fall yes but what if there's something
interesting in the end that this guy
said is about the unrest and then they
can flee so it's not only is there Wars
all over between nations but we what
about civil war Civil War and internal
unrest and there's a lot of talk about
that as
well so we can expect a lot of civil
unrest right MH uh is it possible that
we can even expect Civil War I think is
more than possible in various countries
yeah it's not excluded in our country
here in southern Africa it's definitely
not excluded in Europe it's definitely
not excluded uh even in the East block
no and what about the United States of
America it's well there's some really
disturbing movements going on so if a
Cyber attack comes or there's a grid
failure and uh The Divide between those
that have been able to take care of
themselves and those that have not been
able to take care of themselves becomes
greater then you can get tremendous
civil unrest right it's almost also as
if are we be being
prepared um desensitized towards this
yes so the movies are certainly doing
their work desensitizing people let's
have a look at this clip from takal
and it's gotten to the point now where
it's getting so condensed you know these
suitcase dirty bombs whatever they are
you could definitely rig one of those up
and hook it to a a scud missile put it
on a cargo ship just off the United
States uh Coast send it up to a certain
altitude explode it and uh how that
would what they call a super EMP which
is electromagnetic pulse which is the
same thing as a GE
thermal event you with the sun it's uh
if you send up a missile a
nuclear uh with a nuclear uh bomb on it
it exploded at
400 kilometers above the Earth in space
basically you won't you won't see it you
won't see the explosion because it's in
a vacuum of space you you won't hear it
no people will be killed but the gamma
rays which are thrown out from that
would Encompass most of the United
States and take out this very same
grid and with then which could cause a
power outage all across the United
States up
to months even a year and we'd have the
same scenario that we descried you hate
even to game it out but like if that
happened if huge parts of the United
States had no power for a year I mean
that that I mean that' be an Extinction
event for a lot like yeah they done a
study and 90% of of the population would
be dead within a year you know in 18
during this carington event I mean one
thing we didn't rely on electricity you
know and everybody had a cow if you
wanted milk and you had a horse if you
wanted to drive you your car wouldn't
work you would you do your telephone
doesn't work there's no way to inform
the public about you know anything
anything soten it's not necessary that
it'll happen but they're talking about
it well it's let's put it this way it's
a POS it can happen it's not putting it
that it will happen but there's nothing
that tells you that it can't happen
because everything is there to make it
happen if somebody does this you'll have
that problem now we are in a very
fortunate position here in southern
Africa because we have power outages all
the time so a grit failure is a given
for us and uh you know we're ready for
it whatever happens and we even joke
about it but if you if you take this
picture and you transfer it to a nation
where you have winter storms and all of
a sudden cities are without without heat
that would be a different story right
but even like you said you remember we
got even with the power outage that we
have we don't have it nonstop for a
month or two months no after that not
even a battery will even work anymore or
diesel your Audi it's going to be well
if something like this let's just say
there are some scary things that can
happen yes
particularly since we've become so
accustomed to living that way but we've
got um Adon admonition to grow our own
things to look after ourselves and get
out of the cities and get out of the
Cities get out of the
Cities all right Martin now we're going
to have a look at some clips from some
movies just inform us as to what's
Happening Here Yeah they well there's
two movies the one is already out and
the other one is still coming the one is
Leave the World Behind and that is about
well similar to what Dennis quate just
explained um there's an event there no
cell phones no and everything just
collapses and the second one is about
Civil War so it's interesting that um
while all of this is happening around
the world it's like we asked AR are we
being desensitized towards what's it
going are we being prepared for
something let's have a look there was
one program in particular that terrified
my client the most a simple three-stage
maneuver that could top AO country's
government from
within first stage was
isolation disable their communication
and
transportation make the target as deaf
dumb and paralyzed as possible setting
them up for the second
stage synchronized
chaos terrorized them with covert
attacks and
misinformation overwhelming their
defense capabilities leaving their
weapon systems vulnerable to extremists
in their own
military without a clear enemy or motive
people would start turning on each
other done
successfully third stage would happen on
its
own of War 19 states have suceeded the
United States Army ramps of activity the
White House issued warnings to the
Western forces as well as the Florida
Alliance the three ter president assures
the uprising will be dealt with swiftly
are you guys aware there's like a pretty
huge civil war going on all across
America with what we see on the news
seems like it's for the
best citizens of America the so-called
Western forces of Texas and California
suffered a very great defeat at the
hands of the United States military Mr
President and do you regret the use of
air strikes against American citizens
there's some kind of misunderstanding
here look we American
okay okay what kind of American are you
God Bless
[Music]
[Applause]
America all right so Jesuit theater is
preparing the world mhm well Martin we
know that they know something because
they're in tune with the dark Forces of
this world mhm now and look at how
predictive they were before the
pandemic what about that military
documents that we' just saw that was
leaked out of the German military yes
you remember we read all of those
documents also written well beforehand
as to exactly how the recent scenarios
should have panned out and they panned
out exactly like they should right yeah
they said two to three
years here's an article from the BBC
which states that bomb threats cause
evacuations at multiple US state
houses state capital buildings in at
least six states were evacuated on
Wednesday after being targeted by bomb
threats a Kentucky Secretary of State
spokeswoman said the threat came in a
mass email sent to sever State offices
across the US the BBC has reviewed the
email which targeted at least 24 State
houses and appears to have caused many
to close at the start of the new
legislative session no bombs have been
discovered and the FBI is
investigating so this is constant
fear-mongering of what is happening and
you see the thing is it's this rumors
the whole
time so how serious is this I think we
can know that it's pretty serious all
right let's go to manuscript
114 and read what it says there in India
China Russia and the cities of America
thousands of men and women are dying of
Salvation the moneyed men because they
have the power control the market they
purchase at low rates all they can
obtain and then sell it greatly
increased prices this means starvation
to the poorer classes and will result in
a civil
war now various countries are mentioned
there so you cannot be very specific
here but Civil Wars will break out
that's what it says right yeah and just
to make sure this is not referring to
the Civil Wars that are in history no no
this is
future there will be future a time of
trouble such as never was since there
was a nation at that time shall Michael
stand up the great Prince which standeth
for the children of thy people and there
shall be a time of trouble such as never
was since there was a nation even to
that same time and at that time thy
people shall be delivered everyone that
shall be found written in the book many
shall be purified and made white and
tried but the wicked shall do wickedly
and none of the wicked will understand
but the wise will understand so we need
to become wise and the only way to
become wise is to study the word that's
the only thing so if we ask are we
prepared we don't mean are we getting
our arms ready and our guns loaded no no
are you getting prepared with the word
of God yes are you asking yourself the
question am I right with
God and we will see some interesting
things in a moment now Martin a lot of
legislation has been introduced into the
world because of so-called catastrophes
that are coming that are blamed on
various issues whether it be climate
change or
whatever and legislation that is really
touching the pockets of the man in the
street yeah and there's a lot of
anger whether this is a
plan or whether it is by chance that
these things happen history will tell or
at least the judgment will
tell but if I know the devil then he has
strategies MH and if he has agents on
this Earth and he has many of
them then he will transform or transfer
that strategy to his agents on this
Earth and there will be civil unrest we
which we are already seeing let's have a
look at some of these
issues what you you said is correct a
lot of media are absolutely ignoring the
massive protests that are going on right
now in Germany as you know I'm from the
Netherlands and we uh we are neighboring
countries to uh to Germany and I've been
very involved in the protests of the
farmers over in my home country and when
I heard that the German farmers were
going out to protest I thought to myself
I need to be there the reason the German
farmers are protesting right now um is
actually because a decision by the
German government government sparked a
lot of anger uh the German government
has decided to uh to basically eliminate
a tax break on agricultural Diesel and
that's not just you know the only thing
that they've done in the past few years
to uh to attack and basically harass the
the German Farmers the German farmers
are subjected just like the Dutch
farmers and a lot of farmers around the
Western world uh to all sorts of new
regulations and restrictions all of the
time this is a a protest that we haven't
seen
um in this type of this type of
magnitude in Germany ever
before I'm M legislation against Farmers
is it only a European issue or is it a
worldwide issue it's a worldwide issue
but do they want starvation
exactly what else can it be because that
is the one area that you really want to
look after because that without food
everybody dies and then you can blame
the calamities on whatever issue that
you want and you can choose your issue
you can say it's climate change you can
say it's racism you can say it's
elitism whatever you can say it's
communism you can say it's capitalism
whatever your bandwagon is jump on it
but just create enough chaos so that you
have starvation and is this causing
ruptions these people are getting
agitated everywhere so you see the
chance of this escalating more and more
as people get more agitated is not
farfetched and the world media is not
speaking about the responses they're
only talking about the issues right so
here's an article from
brib
10,000 expected at German tractor
protest as truckers join the Rebels the
rebels right for truckers issues pushing
them to the protest today and to launch
other protests of their own later in the
week include Rising CO2
pricing a further tax upon operating an
engine driven vehicle on top of the rest
means to punish producers of emissions
and Rising toll road prices tractor
protesters themselves are also at odds
with the government policies that seek
to raise more cash for the state by
punishing those who use machines in
agricultural case this means increased
fuel costs by the government withdrawing
a diesel subsidy and ending the taxation
exemption for agricultural vehicles and
this is all based on climate change and
CO2 yeah which I have always maintained
and I also have a science background
this is a load of nonsense but uh that
will cause many to raise their hackles
but let that be as it may
there's another article from The
Washington Post over 1 million rally in
Germany against Rising power of far
right party yeah so you have the left
agitating against the right the right
agitating against the left is this a
recipe for civil war no for sure and we
this is in Germany so Europe Europe is
also and it's not only there it's it
and a lot of places that are stirring so
after months of surging popularity of
the afd the report appears to have
served as a wakeup call for Germans
opposing the group and an estimated 1.4
million people hitting the streets over
the weekend so you have the right
political
parties demonizing the left and vice
versa is the same happening in the
United States yes it's happening
worldwide
worldwide okay so let's have a look at
what's happening in the United States
well DeSantis just ended his
presidential campaign and he endorsed
Trump it's interesting right he was
quite fiery against Trump yeah and now
he says it's only with the
pandemic dealing with the pandemic
that so FL Florida Governor Ronda santz
who entered the Republican presidential
primary as Donald Trump's greatest
threat announced Sunday that he is
ending his White House bid and endorsing
the former president he then touted his
support for Trump while I've had
disagreements with Donald Trump such as
the Corona virus pandemic and his
elevation of Anthony fouchi Trump is
superior to the current incumbent Joe
Biden that is
clear so it seems to be heading towards
a one horse race it's still a two horse
race but let's see where that
ends and then of of course his other
opponent ramas Swami also suspended his
campaign and also endorsed Donald Trump
and he said he made the decision after
determining there was no path forward
for him in the race absent things that
we don't want to see happen in this
country is the
38-year-old political novice who sought
to replicate Trump's rise as a bombastic
wealthy Outsider said he called the
former president earlier Monday evening
to congratulate at him on his victory in
Iowa and then of course we know the rest
yeah and Nikki Haley is the only one
standing against Trump at this stage
yes and that brings us Martin to uh one
of the pet subjects in the world namely
the world economic
forum and uh this year they opened their
ceremony at Davos with a witch doctor's
performance
so what what spirit is is reigning there
you see usually there was n no none of
this spiritualistic or any religion
involved in this but now it's really
showing its colors can you separate
religion from politics no from economics
no
okay and you know but by looking at
these people and determining how they
think and what they say is it very
difficult to discern whether they on the
side of the Bible or against it no not
that at all you don't need brains for
that right you can you can have one
ganglion firing and and you should be
able to discern that yeah
okay all right here's an article about
the world economic
Forum which doctor's performance adds
new dimension in an unpr precedented
moment at the renowned world economic
Forum in Davos an unusual spectacle
unfolded as a traditional Witch Doctor
took Center Stage performing
incantations and engaging attendees in a
spiritual experience distinct from the
forum's typical business and political
undertakings a shift from the
conventional now M This Is Not Unusual
it took place at CERN it takes place all
over the world it takes place at the
Olympics they're all bringing in these
Pagan rituals right well it's even taken
place at the Vatican so absolutely so
they're really showing their true colors
and where they are heading so let's look
at some of these
things sh
[Music]
I well Martin I hope they're happy with
that ruach because that Spirit blowing
through there is obviously not the same
one that was experienced at Pentecost is
it no all right let's just leave let's
just leave it there that's is not a
study for
that but that's yeah you can see like
you mentioned we you cannot dis um take
religion away no out of this now has
everybody in the world been happy with
what's been happening at the world
economic Forum or has it become even
somewhat of a joke oh definitely a lot
of people are quite SP outspoken these
days at the world economic forum okay so
let's have a look at the president of
Argentina and what he thought about the
situation do not be intimidated
intimidated either by the political cast
or by parasites who live off the state
do not surrender to a political class
that only wants to stain power and
retain its privileges do not surrender
to the advance of the state the state is
not the solution the state is the
problem itself you are the true
protagonists of this story and rest
assured that as from today Argentina is
your sta unconditional Ally thank you
very much and Long Live Freedom damn
it Mar was he happy with them no he's
not happy with any socialism he even
remember we showed just before we ended
with the last year with him speaking
against the pope yes about his
socialistic views and everything so no
is very much
for capitalism actually so is there a
divide coming big big time right the
world Heritage Foundation also had
something to say on the issue right or
their spokesperson at least very
interesting and he didn't agree
necessarily with some of the sentiments
definitely not let's have a look one
thing that Davos you might say and the
people come here stand up for is liberal
democracy it's laughable that you would
or anyone would describe Davos as
protecting liberal
democracy I'll be candid here because I
think I've been invited here to be
candid Elites tell us that we we have
this existential crisis with so-called
climate change the solutions the average
person know cost more human lives
especially in Europe during the time
that you need heating than do the
problem and the problems themselves the
kind of person who will come into the
next conservative Administration is
going to be governed by one principle
and that is
destroying the grasp that political
Elites and unelected technocrats have
over the average person and if I may I
will be candid and say that the agenda
that every single member of the
administration needs to have is to
compile a list of everything that's ever
been proposed at the world economic
forum and object all of them
wholesale all right let's let's just
take that last statement it's a very
interesting statement compile a list of
every anything that has ever been
decided at the world economic forum and
then do the
opposite reject it all right
yeah and this person is speaking on
behalf of the Heritage
Foundation did they perhaps set up a
document as to the political
future in the United States for example
perfectly and they said that the new
president if it's a republican will
immediately Implement that and is Sunday
legislation part of
that entrenched in it a whole section so
Martin is this a possibility that this
pendulum from this nonsense will swing
in the opposite direction if you have to
take the candidate for president that
will be able to do this unfortunately it
just seems like it will be Trump all
right so let's say Trump does come to
power
then you will have this implementation I
think
so and maybe it will even lead to a
civil war it
may but there is a
determination to come back to what we
call our spiritual roots and they are
not Pagan no they are
Christian but what if they are based on
the false premises of Rome rather than
the scripture that's exactly isn't that
a double whammy that the devil is oh
definitely and say for
instance a Democrat
wins there can also be say for let's put
a scenario out there say for instance a
Democrat wins and they again say that
the election was stolen that can also
lead to a Civil War and that can throw
the whole thing back and then and over
you don't we don't know but definitely
chaos is coming chaos is coming Z
climate change has been a very big issue
right well especially at the world
economic Forum as well yes and that's
why they're pushing for all of these
agendas that are leading to all of these
unrests because the tractor guys and the
truckers are striking because of things
that were decided at the world economic
forum and that was implemented now taka
Carlson re recently had an interview
with a scientist that was a har
Professor who resigned as a Harvard
Professor because he refused to take the
shot so he has principles this
man and he is quite a renowned scientist
or very capable scientist with a part of
a very great group and he's going to
talk about some of the issues revolving
around this climate change issue let's
just listen to what he has to say Willie
soon has been thinking about this for a
long time he's an astrophysicist a
geoscientist he spent 30 years at
Harvard since I work so carefully and I
have about more than 100 scientists last
three years alone working with me so I
don't speak on behalf of them I speak on
behalf of myself my view is that the un
ipcc united nation intergovernmental
panel on climate change is one of the
primary problem which mean they have
been misleading people they've been
using authority of science which is not
true right it's all governmental hackers
basically right people like carry who I
guess can barely take a a proper physics
class who keep claiming that greenhouse
effect is so simple right and then uh he
refused to explain how does it work
right I mean he did all of that that is
very terrible that really embarrassing
to America he did that in Bali in
Indonesia several years back that is
just so embarrassed do you think he can
explain how it works no I don't think so
even El Gore who claimed to be know
something about sence I challenge Child
G I I did some of that to with in in his
face actually I have I was lucky enough
to be in one of those Wall Street
Journal Eco conference and I was giving
you know setting up with all the UC
Santa Barbara Student please make sure
when the question come out give me the
mic I was making friends with them the
night before I explain now my details of
my work so I I got the mic and ask
question about El go because one of the
primary sad thing that they refuse to
recognize that I know you know that in
in even Grade School uh Sciences CO2 is
a guas of life it when you have more CO2
the plant kingdom the whole ecology even
the oceans going to have more basically
ability more fishes More Everything more
life more life essentially that's why
it's called gas of life and these people
want to demonize it as some gas that can
cause global warming can cause hurricane
to run faster or weaker I don't know
what they want to have more rain more
droughts and all these other nonsense
that they claim all of that it just
ain't so Martin it just ain't so bottom
line I am so happy that we've been
consistent in saying that this CO2
nonsense is just that a load of nonsense
that percentage in the atmosphere is so
infinitesimally small it cannot possibly
be a contributor to climate change but
uh they are using models and they are
using mathematics iCal
formulas and uh they are talking exactly
what this man said nonsense Y and so
there are quite a few jokes about this
right yeah let's look at one I quite
like this one I'm sure this is not of
course the ussl gore but it's still very
fitting ussl Gore global warming
research vessel we're having some of the
coldest winters ever and that's why they
don't really talk about global warming
anymore they talk about climate
change you know what the thing is this
is still a tool that they use to get
what they want yes but they're making
people angry yeah angry enough to swing
the pendulum the other way and to stir
now and so they have all this this
legislation in place so let's just hear
what Weinstein has to say on the issue a
public heal emergency which the director
general of the World Health Organization
has total Liberty to Define in any way
that he sees fit in other words nothing
prevents um climate change from being
declared a public health emergency that
would trigger the provisions of these
modifications we continue to see
misinformation on social media and in
mainstream media about the pandemic
Accord that countries are now negoti
ating the claim that the Accord will
seed power to who is quite simply false
it's fake news countries will decide
what the Accord says and countries alone
and countries will implement the Accord
in line with their own National laws no
country will seed any sovereignity to wh
if any politician business person or
anyone at all is confused about about
what the pandemic Accord is and isn't we
would be more than happy to discuss it
on the one hand I must say I had not
seen that and um it is tremendously good
news actually what it means is that once
again we have managed to raise awareness
of something in time that there is uh
conceivably a better outcome still
available to us so those were clearly
lies and of course uh his saying that
into a camera is supposed to to convince
you you know nobody could possibly lie
so directly so there must be some truth
in what he's saying which is of course
nonsense and anybody who goes back
through uh you know Matt Ora's
compendium of various things that people
have said into cameras over the course
of covid that they then swear they
didn't say you know months later um
knows that these folks are very
comfortable at saying totally false
things into a camera doesn't cause them
to to think twice or sweat or anything
is actually the Department of Homeland
Security actually issued a memo um in
which it defined three kinds of I could
you not terrorism misis and malformation
misinformation are errors uh
disinformation are intentional errors
lies and malformation are things that
are based in truth but cause you to
distrust Authority discussing the lies
of your your government uh is
malformation and therefore a kind of
terrorism which I should point out as
funny as that is and as obviously
orwellian as that is it's also
terrifying because if you have tracked
the history of the spreading tyranny
from the beginning of the war on terror
you know that terrorism is not a normal
English word the way it once was
terrorism is now a legal designation
that causes all of your rights to
evaporate so at the point that the
Department of Homeland Security says
that you are guilty of a kind of
terrorism for saying true things that
cause you to distrust your government
they are also telling you something
about what rights they have to silence
you they are not normal rights
Martin that beside didn't the pope
declare those that are fundamentalists
in other words believe the Bible as
terrorists as terrorists so what rights
do you have none none but I think we
should tell the Pope that we prefer to
believe the Bible rather than his
misinformation oh for sure you see we
spread Mal information because it's the
truth but we caught him out okay so
biblical Mal information is actually
truth yeah
okay so where does the pope come into
this well the pope to Davos economic
Forum development needs a model compass
in a message to the
2024 World economic Forum in Davos Pope
Francis urges business and world leaders
to ensure that economic development
benefits everyone and remains tied to
solidarity development said the pope
must entail
subordinating the pursuit of power and
individual game be it political or
economic to the common good of our human
family giving priority to the poor the
needy and those in the most vulnerable
situations now who defines the common
good he does he does he does and the
common good is always contrary to the
Bible yes and it's never good for you
the individual it's never good for you
so Martin this is the state of the world
and this is the point where people must
make a decision either for or against
the evil that seems to be in
power now even some of the staunch
supporters of Pope Francis are beginning
to realize that all is not well in the
state of Vatican yeah yeah true so even
if we have sometimes exposed him as a
false prophet there are some truth in
what he's saying in this particular
case as this past year Drew to a close
something seismic happened the
repercussions of which are going to be
felt for years for many of you this is
your wakeup call the Pope the head of
the Catholic Church the one whom
Catholic Doctrine says is the Vicor of
Christ messiah's representative on Earth
decreed that the Catholic church is now
to give its blessings to same-sex unions
after nearly 2,000 years of designating
such things as Grievous sin which has
been the stand of Christianity for 2,000
years the pope has decided that the
Catholic church is now going to bless
these unions Pope Francis and his
leadership has said it's about incl
inclusion and progressing it's about
being loving no it's not about inclusion
or loving we are to love and reach out
with the love of God to everyone but
this is something else what is it I'll
tell you what it is in one word the word
appears in the Bible it's called
apostasy this is the Pope's great moment
of apostasy it's a watershed moment it's
a red flag moment a milestone for
Catholicism and even for Western
Civilization now if you were watching
watching closely you could see it coming
this is the same Pope who warned
Christians against sin no idolatry no
evil no he warned Christians against
quote rigidity of ready The Ten
Commandments against being too set on
the ten commandments so which of the Ten
Commandments must we not become too set
on having other gods Idols coveting
adultery murder which ones exactly
should we become less strong about the
pope went on to say that God gives us
the freedom to search our own conscience
for Commandments really so that thing
that happened on Mount Si with Moses was
a mistake so Moses should have come down
from the mountain and told the
Israelites I have these Ten Commandments
in stone but don't get too set on them
search your own conscience for your own
Commandments and if your conscience says
adulter is okay go for it other gods
more power to you worshiping a golden
calf as you're doing right now God bless
you or May the a golden calf bless you
Pope Francis said that someone who holds
strongly to such things as the Ten
Commandments has something wrong with
them does that include Jesus because as
far as I know Jesus was pretty set on
them the pope went on to say that the
Ten Commandments are not a gift from God
really well then who gave them did they
descend to Sinai from a spaceship he
goes on to say that while the Ten
Commandments are not a gift from God the
Beatitudes are because quote they make
you feel good the Beatitudes are part of
a sermon in which the Lord Messiah said
if you even look at a woman in lust
you're committing adultery it's hyper
Ten Commandments I mean a 10-year-old
Sunday school student would know that
but the pope apparently did not read
that far into it and he said this I
always try to understand what's behind
people who are too young to have seen
Moses walk down from Mount Si with the
Ten Commandments and yet they still want
to obey them did he actually say that
what is that they shouldn't follow the
ten commandments because the command
commments came a while back if you
weren't there it doesn't count forget
about them if you're not over 3,000
years old don't worry about it well
Martin he spoke a lot about the Ten
Commandments but he left out one
unfortunately but he is a Jewish rabbi
yes so she he should be very excited
about the fourth Commandment as well and
the pope obviously is not excited about
the fourth Commandment because he likes
to trample upon it exactly and says it
is his priority or
prerogative to change that commandment
to show that he's the one in authority
and not God so M this is a great
evil and how this power can call itself
Christian when it negates the
atonement when it introduces Purgatory
where you pay for your own sins and
therefore makes null and void the cross
is a travesty which is beyond
comprehension and even when I was a
Roman Catholic I never thought about
those things but studying the word of
God the enormity of the
crime against humanity and against the
god of Heaven is so enormous that only
total
obliteration which is Promised by the
Bible will actually rid the world of
this evil
now how do we stand in this conflict we
have to make a choice yeah do we pick up
arms no no the only arms that we pick up
is the armor of God that's the only
thing so Sammons and talks God help you
to begin the work right here not to wait
for the ministers to stir you up to a
wonderful
excitement God wants intelligent
Christians he wants you to count the
cost of the battle he wants you to count
whether you can war against Satan and
his spiritual wickedness in high
places can you yes with with his help
yes but you can't in your own strength
right so picking up an axe or a weapon
of War won't help you who are you going
to shoot are you going to shoot the
devil he wants you to see the plan of
the battle of the Confederacy of
evil people always say don't talk about
these things only talk about the love no
it says here he wants you to understand
this Confederacy of evil so that you can
make a decided decision against it
exactly because otherwise you will just
G okay it's okay we can accept because
God loves him we accept the evil all
right and if you see the
Confederacy and you see its enormous
power and Rich then he wants you to see
the angel angs that are in his
army that the captain of our Salvation
is at the head in other words you look
at the issue and who's really fighting
against this issue Jesus why is Jesus
allowing the evil to raise its head to
the extent that it is that everybody
with half a brain can see the evil
behind it why is he allowing it so that
you can make a choice exactly so that
you can make a
choice it is they that do the work it is
the angels and the captain and we
cooperate
coincide and work with them how do we
work with them by preaching the gospel
by preaching the solution by preaching
the love of Christ by preaching the
atonement by preaching salvation in
Christ and Christ Alone this is how we
war against this enemy
so when we go out and you've watched a
episode like this you don't go and
scream at everybody to start listening
to what's going on you get them to the
Bible yes and then we must confront this
Confederacy of evil and God will put an
end to it and he's going to put an end
to it very soon and then it will be too
late to make a decision make the
decision now here are they that keep the
Commandments
and have the testimony of Jesus here are
they that keep the Commandments and have
the faith of Jesus blessed are though
that keep the Commandments that they may
have the right to the Tree of Life yeah
obedience to God obedience to the powers
that be under the
dragon that is our choice that's a
choice may God help us to make the right
one let's
pray heavenly father the world is on the
brink of Calamity and God's people are
sleeping please Lord wake them up time
is over it's happening give us the
wisdom and the strength to choose the
right side to enlist in the Army in the
army that will
eventually sweep away the Refuge of Lies
is my prayer in jesus' name amen
[Music]
amen